-Our next guest
is an award-winning TV
and comic-book writer.
His graphic novel "Adora and
the Distance" is on sale now.
Please welcome to the show
Marc Bernardin.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to the show.
-Hey! This is awesome.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
You -- Let's be honest.
You launched a successful
social-media campaign
to get yourself on this show.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
There's a comic-book writer
named Mark Waid
who always says
that breaking into comics
is like breaking out of prison.
No two people do it
the same way,
and they seal up the hole
after you're done.
-Right.
-So there is no way that
this is gonna work again,
but I had to talk about
this comic book
for, like, a month and a half.
I was like,
"Well, let's gamify it.
Let's have a good time with it.
Let's see if I can
get on 'Seth Meyers.'"
What are the odds that at
the beginning of this thing --
Like, "Yeah, no,
Seth will see it,
and Seth will be like,
'Yeah, man, come on the show.'
Let's talk about
your comic book.'"
And now I'm on "Seth Meyers"
talking about my comic book.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, it should be noted, I --
One of the things
that helped this campaign
is I am a big comic-book fan.
I follow a lot of comic-book
writers on Twitter.
I'm friends with a lot
of comic-book writers.
And it kept coming across
my Twitter feed,
because a lot of people
I liked and trusted
liked and trusted you.
So that helped a great deal,
as well.
You seem very beloved
within the field.
-All of the checks
have cleared.
-Yeah.
-So I feel good about that now.
Not wasted money at all.
-Yeah.
Now, so this -- You know,
this is, it should be noted,
one of the reasons
you want to talk about it.
This is a special comic.
This was inspired by
your daughter who has autism.
-Indeed.
-And why did you want
to tell a story about her
and her autism
in this comic format?
-Well, when she was diagnosed --
At this point, she's 19.
So this was like 15 years ago.
Like, lots of my friends
were like,
"Well, you should
write about it.
You're a journalist.
You know how to do this.
You should write
some kind of memoir
about raising
an autistic child."
And I'm like, "I am
the least interesting person
in this story."
I don't know what's happening
in her head.
I never do.
She's not that verbal.
She can't tell me
what she's feeling.
She can't tell me if she is sad
or if she's happy.
All I know is "I want chicken
nuggets" and "I'm sleepy."
-Mm-hmm.
-Like, that's what I got.
And so I then imagined what
this interior life for her was,
and it became this sort of
process of building the metaphor
of, here's a girl on a quest,
trying to get to the end
of her journey.
And what's at the end
of this journey?
And it's -- Because I'm a nerd
and I grew up on, like,
"Lord of the Rings"
and "Star Wars"
and "Raiders of the Lost Ark,"
there's running and jumping
and adventure,
and there's knights
and there's all of this stuff.
But it's ultimately about a girl
trying to get from one world
to the other.
-And your antagonist in this,
which is, I think,
unique to a comic book,
when we talk about
the convention of it,
isn't a character,
it's not a villain so much.
It is this sort of
vaguer idea of the distance.
When did you come up with that?
And explain, real quick,
what it represents.
-I came up with it
very early on.
The distance is, not to spoil
too much about it,
but it's the place she is going.
In the story within the story,
it's a force.
It's like a hurricane
or a tsunami.
It's a storm that's tearing
everything apart on its way
to get to this girl.
And so what she wants to do
to save her friends
and her family is confront
the distance where it is.
But I didn't want it to be bad.
I didn't want a bad guy.
I just wanted somebody
who had a dream
and had a hope and wanted
to protect the people she loved.
I didn't need to slay dragons
to get that done.
-So, I hope I'm saying
her name right. Ariela?
-Ariela Kristantina.
-So you have an incredible
illustrator here.
And I want to ask, like,
when you, you know --
I've been lucky enough
one or two times to write stuff
that then gets, you know,
that an illustrator
turns in work,
which is so incredible.
Were you very specific
with what you wanted,
or did you just sort of tell her
to use her talents?
-I was specific
about the things
that I knew were emotional.
But then I said,
"Listen. You can draw.
I can't.
So, please, make it awesome."
And she, like,
took it on her back
and she, like, shouldered
this burden
of doing all the research.
Like, what does a 14th-century
port city look like? Okay?
And she would, like, send me
these reference pages of,
here's the Moroccan
influence here,
and there's a bit of Moors
in here
and here's a little bit of this.
[ Gasps ]
Like, every page was like --
"Oh, my God. This is amazing!"
And, like, the main character,
Adora,
I had written her
sort of blankly.
You know, it was,
she's 9 years old,
curly hair,
she goes on a quest.
And Ariela is the one who came
back with this little brown girl
with this massive bush of hair.
And I was like,
"Where'd this come from?"
She was like, "Well,
it's your daughter, right?
So she should look like you."
And then I started to cry,
because that's what happens.
And then just said,
"Okay, keep going.
Like, don't even wait
for me to tell you things.
Just make it awesome."
And she did.
-That's great. You also --
You host a podcast with
friend of the show Kevin Smith.
-Yes.
-And Kevin is a lot of fun
when he's here.
I can only imagine --
You know, if anything,
when he's here,
the only thing I'm sad about is
how little time I have with him.
In a podcast form, you probably
get a full -- a full share.
-Oh, I get two and a half hours
a clip of unadulterated Kevin.
-Yeah.
-And I get to be sort of
his weed GPS.
-Yeah.
-You know, 'cause when he --
'cause, I don't know
if you guys know this,
but Kevin likes to smoke.
-Smoke weed?
-A little bit. A little bit.
-Yeah.
This is breaking news here.
-[ Laughs ]
You should be a journalist.
And, so, like, I get to
pull him out of the fog bank
cul-de-sacs where it's like,
"Now, where were we?"
-Right.
-It's like, "Oh, we were
talking about Moon Knight."
"Oh, right. That's cool.
I love Moon Knight."
He -- When I told him
I was coming, he was like,
"you should bring Seth a joint,
because there's a joint on his
desk and it needs a friend."
I was like, "Kevin, you are
an internationally famous actor,
director, filmmaker, raconteur.
I am a anonymous
husky Black gentleman
who will be ferrying marijuana
across state lines.
I don't think so, pal.
Not gonna end so well for me."
-Yeah.
Well, your instincts are good,
but I will say, I'm glad
Kevin checked on his joint.
We still have it.
This is -- This --
He brought this,
I think, three years ago.
And --
-I'm sure it's great now.
-He dared me to keep it here
as long as I could,
and I have it now.
I feel like
it's just fully legal now.
[ Laughter ]
-And now you can't smoke it,
because you'll get superpowers.
-Exactly.
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations
on both the campaign
and this really, really
wonderful book.
-Oh, thank you.
-Thank you so much.
Marc Bernardin, everybody.
"Adora and the Distance"
is on sale now.